as I told you yesterday Republicans in
the House and Senate have passed finally
the new Trump Republican tax plan which
Donald Trump is not expected to sign
until January I do think it's important
to do a full analysis of the bill and on
tomorrow's program we'll talk about how
the bill will affect Donald Trump in his
inner circle personally many of you
probably have guesses as to how that
will shake out but let's get into an
analysis of what finally made it into
the bill because we've talked about the
different provisions over time that may
have been in the bill or were in one
version of the bill but not the other
but now that it's passed let's actually
figure out what's in this bill and as we
get into this remember that most of the
changes expire after 2025
at which point more than half of
Americans will actually see a tax
increase not a tax cut more than 50% of
Americans but let's talk about what
changes at least in the short and medium
term and first and foremost is tax
brackets right this has been the subject
of an insane amount of controversy and
discussion these images that will be
showing you for our TV audience are from
the New York Times analysis of this
which was quite good and the key point
here is that the top tax rate comes down
there are changes made to tax rates for
lower earners and the amount of money
that those individuals will save or lose
out on is basically a drop in the bucket
compared to the savings that the very
rich will get as a result of that top
tax bracket coming down you'll see that
under current law that top tax bracket
the marginal tax bracket is thirty nine
point six percent and under the recently
passed Republican bill that top rate
will be 37 percent a two point six
percentage point decrease but if you're
earning a lot of money that is a
stunning amount of tax savings that you
will experience at the expense of of
course the deficit increasing and
somebody else making it up if you want
to find a situation in which that the
deficit does not increase it note
notably by the way the new top tax
bracket coming down but not as low as it
was under george w bush make of
that what you will next is standard
deductions and exemptions so I want to
explain this again before we dive into
how it's changing under the Trump tax
bill there are two ways to do your taxes
one is that you itemized your deductible
expenses you go through and you say okay
I paid $3,000 in mortgage interest which
is deductible I paid X amount in medical
expenses beyond the minimum threshold
which is deductible you go through the
list and you add it up and you take an
actual deduction that is equal to your
actual deductible expenses during the
year the other option is to take what's
called a standard deduction that's a
predetermined amount that every taxpayer
is entitled to deduct off of their taxes
regardless of what their itemized
deductions actually where your itemized
deductions might have been less or more
either way you have the option to take
the standard deduction although of
course if your itemized deductions
exceed the standard deduction you're
better off taking those in the new Trump
Republican tax bill you will see that
the standard deduction goes up from
$6,500 for single people to $12,000 for
single people and from $13,000 for
couples to $24,000 for couples and in
addition to that personal exemptions are
being eliminated previously each
taxpayer and dependent was entitled to a
four thousand one hundred and fifty
dollar personal exemption which you also
don't pay taxes on so what's the effect
of this right the deduction doubles so
more people take it but the personal
exemptions go away which is something
Republicans want they want to get people
away from many of these individual
deductions and later they can look at
actually getting rid of some deductions
altogether and for bigger families this
could actually result in a tax increase
when you combine the increase in the
standard deduction with the elimination
altogether of the forty one hundred and
fifty dollar personal exemption again
it's going to depend on the specific
circumstances of each family part of the
reason why Republicans want to do this
is they want to get away
from some of these deductions that
disproportionately are actually good for
low and middle income earners and we'll
get to that a little bit later in the
analysis let's talk about family tax
credits okay family tax credits are also
changing under this tax plan the child
tax credit is being doubled from $1,000
to $2,000 but the key thing is that the
income limit for these credits goes way
up
so now far wealthier families are going
to be able to take advantage of this
under the previous plan the family tax
credit started to phase out when an
individual earned over seventy five
thousand dollars a year or a couple
earned over a hundred and ten thousand
dollars a year now not only are the tax
credits increasing but you will be
eligible for them all the way up to two
fully eligible all the way up to two
hundred thousand dollars a year in
income as an individual and twice that
four hundred thousand dollars as a
couple that is one way in which you are
going to expand the tax savings of the
wealthier individuals relative to lower
and middle income earners another major
issue itemized deductions earlier in the
analysis I explained to you how there
has been a doubling of the standard
deduction and I said part of what
Republicans would like to do is get away
from some of the individual itemized
deductions
one issue is the state and local tax
deduction currently any income or sales
or property taxes that you pay to your
municipality or to your state are
deductible from your federal taxes that
saves you federal tax for the paying of
taxes at the state and local level under
the new plan
all state and local tax deductions will
be limited to ten thousand dollars you
can only deduct those first ten thousand
dollars that you pay this is a huge
redistribution of money away from higher
tax states typically blue states which
will then subsidize the lower tax states
that often have the worse infrastructure
quickly those are conservative red
states as an example if you live in New
York City which has a higher state
income tax and a city income tax
previously all of those state and local
taxes that you paid reduced your federal
tax bill now you will only be allowed to
deduct the first $10,000 which means
that your taxes paid are gonna go up
significantly if you are in one of those
higher tax blue states to go back to the
itemized deductions if we can pad small
change to the mortgage interest
deduction from a million dollars to
seven hundred and fifty thousand dollars
you know the truth is that if you've got
a million dollar mortgage and you can
only deduct the interest on the first
750,000 of that mortgage you're probably
gonna be fine that's that's really not
going to be a big pain for hire for
people who are privileged enough to have
a million dollar mortgage you can also
no longer deduct moving expenses and
that's actually important for lower and
middle income people if you're a lower
middle-income person who by the way
might be moving more often than a
wealthier person due to housing
instability being able to deduct those
moving expenses is actually something
that can make a difference not going to
make a difference for a rich person
who's moving from one huge house to
another and then medical expenses I
actually agree with this I found a
provision Pat in this this proposal that
I actually agree with the threshold is
being reduced and when we can keep that
up as I explain it the threshold for
deducting medical expenses you used to
only be able to deduct medical expenses
in excess of ten percent of your income
that is being changed to being able to
deduct medical expenses in excess of
seven point five percent of your income
that's actually a good thing for lower
in middle-class taxpayers and here is
the big bonanza for the rich the overall
limit on itemized deductions is being
repealed so previously you stopped being
able to itemize deductions at two
hundred and sixty six thousand dollars
of income for a single person that's
repealed as you see in the new column
here that we're showing our TV and an
online video audience you now have no
income limit
whatsoever on item IDing itemizing
deductions that's a major opportunity
for the rich to pay even less in taxes
what about health care wait a second
health care why is health care part of
this bill health care is part of this
tax bill if we look at how health care
is going to be impacted the individual
mandate the penalty put in place by the
Affordable Care Act for not having
health insurance is being eliminated
starting in 2019 this crushes Obamacare
this absolutely crushes Obamacare this
is a topic on its own that we should
discuss but I did want to mention that
this is part of it the estate tax the
estate tax threshold doubles from five
point six million dollars to eleven
point two million dollars in one's
estate on which you do not pay taxes
this benefits not the top ten percent
not the top five percent not the top one
percent this benefits the top zero point
two percent of the country that has an
estate bigger than five point six
million dollars and then as far as
pass-through income this is also a big
deal for very very rich people pass
through income instead of being taxed at
individual rates you will get a twenty
percent deduction on pass-through income
which will start phasing out at three
hundred and fifteen thousand dollars of
income for couples the claim is that
this is really great for small
businesses but the truth is that 70% of
pass-through income goes to people who
are already in the top one percent so
it's a major handout and then let's talk
about businesses the corporate tax rate
has been a big big deal in the
negotiation of this tax bill and as you
will see the corporate tax rate is down
from thirty five percent to twenty one
percent this doesn't stimulate the
economy I've talked about it before this
is actually an incentive for businesses
to take profits rather than to reinvest
in their businesses and I actually had a
really great analogy presented to me
that couldn't be simpler if a business
has profit go up but they have the same
amount of customers you're not going to
hire more people or invest in the
business you're going to take the
profits and that is exactly
why this is not going to be stimulative
to the economy alternative minimum tax
for businesses that's gone big
businesses love that big businesses
absolutely love that
and another boon to the very rich and to
big businesses so what's the big picture
here number one this tax plan is great
for the rich number two this tax plan is
great for big corporations and it's
going to create some modest changes for
most taxpayers now Republicans in
touting how great the bill is they will
cherry-pick really specific family
situations like they'll pick someone
who's on the top end of a tax bracket
who might have seen or will see a
decrease in the tax they pay so they'll
say if you earn seventy three thousand
dollars a year which gets you right in
the seventy seven thousand dollar limit
at which point you go to the next tax
bracket and you have X number of kids
and they'll create these very specific
scenarios that benefit their narrative
the broader macro analysis is that over
the long term for more than half of all
Americans taxes will go up as a result
of this and the deficit is going to go
up we are looking at a 1.5 trillion
dollar increase to the deficit over 10
10 years Trump and his cronies are
saying this is going to be so good for
the economy we're gonna have four
percent GDP growth next year even
Goldman Sachs doesn't believe that
Goldman Sachs decided to do their own
analysis and they believe that this tax
bill is going to create point seventy
five percent growth in the next two
years which will not exceed the increase
to the deficit to the extent that that
matters and Republicans claim that it
does and then it those positive impacts
are going to evaporate completely now
the stock market might keep going up
okay and you have to be prepared for
Republicans and Trump touting the
success of the tax bill in the continued
growth of the stock market but why is
the stock market going to go up because
if businesses are allowed to keep more
profits and pay those profits out to
shareholders that's good for the stock
market so of course it will go up but it
will mostly benefit high-income earners
and the corporations themselves so
basically what we have here is middle
income people that are going to
subsidize stock
market gains that will be paid out
mostly to corporations and rich
shareholders and then lastly as the
political impact Donald Trump is
fulfilling the campaign promise of
passing a tax bill but this is not
fulfilling his campaign promise of a tax
cut for everyone it's not fulfilling the
promise of a tax cut for the middle
class and remember when he said in an
interview something like his hedge fund
friends won't be happy with him over the
tax bill they are very happy because
this is great for them so the question
that remains politically is will the
trumpets be happy that Trump passed a
tax bill or will they be upset that he
passed a total corporatist Oleg article
handout that's not actually good for the
middle class I don't know the answer
most of the stuff based on my reading is
going to be enacted during 2018 for
taxes to be filed in April of 2019 so
other than a slight change in how much
money you get in your paycheck people
may not really see the full impact of
this until nearly the middle of 2019 so
I don't know what the political
repercussions will be the trumpets will
maybe be bamboozled by Trump because he
passed a bill but this is not a bill
that does what he promised to do with a
tax bill during his entire campaign send
me your thoughts we will have continued
analysis and discussion of this tax bill
today and tomorrow I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on twitter at
david pakman show the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership